in 1922 a radio transmitter powers up
ready to make history
nearby since our Sbarro's and with the
words Baros announces the arrival of the
BBC the age of British broadcasting has
truly begun wait a minute how did this
moment ever happen to start a radio
station you need people to have radios
but who has a radio before there's a
radio station high above the muder
Flanders in 1918 floats disembodied
voices the First World War is the
crucible for a new technology sending
speech by radio when the fighting is
done a small but loyal army of
enthusiasts comes home they're a new
breed radio hams a kind of virtual
community scattered across the country
in living rooms garden sheds anywhere
they can get a signal with their
homemade sets then the Marconi company
gets involved at the heart of their team
is the irrepressible Peter Eckersley he
soon tires of sending repetitive test
signals to see how far they go and
starts liven things up a bit
telling jokes singing songs your hounds
lover but the post office he controlled
the air waves aren't amused by such
frivolous content interfering with more
serious uses in 1920 they banned the
station after a barrage of complaints
the post office is forced to relent but
on one condition
radio needs to be regulated they bring
electrical firms together to create a
new entity the British Broadcasting
Company they alone are granted the right
to broadcast radio to the masses they'll
be powered by Britain's biggest
transmitter yet 2 L or an enormous
jumble of valves and wires that takes up
an entire room
and on a foggy night in 1922 2l all
comes to life with 1.5 kilowatts of
power I can throw the voice of Arthur
Burroughs right across one
soon his voice is joined by others in a
medley of news weather and even music
and it's not just harms tuning in young
and old male and female rich and poor
radios span the social spectrum fast
becoming must have household goods and
so it is that the hobby of a few
enthusiasts is standardized and
nationalized when the next world war
comes around and sir notes to the nation
on BBC radio and heard by nine million
listeners thus are the Information Age
came into the whole
[Music]